In this [music] video, I'm going to show
you how to calculate load factor because
high load factors have killed many
pilots. Not only that, but you could get
asked about this on your FAA written
exam or even your check ride. So, let's
take a look at what you need to know as
a pilot. Welcome to Free Pilot Training.
I'm Josh Campbell, and today we're going
to go into a little bit more detail on
load factor. In the last lesson, we
talked about how inertia and weight are
combined into a total force that can put
a strain on the wings of our aircraft.
This is what we call the load or the
load factor. Now, this load factor tells
us how much stress is being placed on
the wings of our aircraft. And we
measure this by something called G
forces or G's. This is simply a
measurement of gravity or in super
simple terms, it's the weight of our
aircraft multiplied. For example, if my
aircraft weighs 2,000 lbs and I pull 2
G's, my wings have 4,000 pounds of
pressure on them because 2,000* 2 is
4,000. This is important to know because
bank angle is directly related to load
factor, especially if you're trying to
maintain level flight during the term or
even if you want to turn the aircraft
while climbing. Now, on the FAA written
exam or even on the check ride, you
might be asked to show how bank angle
and load factor correlate. On the
written test, the FAA will provide you
with this chart and expect you to be
able to make some really basic
calculations. Actually, this first one
isn't even a calculation. You just have
to be able to read a chart. What load
factor can you expect if you make a 30°
bank turn while trying to maintain level
flight in your airplane? Now, it used to
be that you only had this chart and you
actually had to draw a line across here
and guess what this number over here
was, but now they basically made this
dummy proof by adding this scale over
here. So, if you can't figure this out,
you should probably just forget becoming
a pilot because as you can see, at 30°
angle of bank, we should expect to pull
exactly 1.154gs.
Too easy, right? Before I move on, I do
want to mention that this figure comes
directly from the FAA testing
supplement, which you can download for
free from a lot of different places. In
fact, it's one of the free products I
have over on my website at
freepilotraining.net.
And you're going to want to download
this because this book has all the real
figures that the FAA actually uses on
the test. And if you practice with this
thing now, it's really going to help
you. Okay, here's one that's a little
bit tougher. What is the total load on
an airplane that weighs 1,475
pounds if the aircraft is banked to 45
degrees during a level turn? Don't
worry, this one's not as hard as it
sounds. We just have to solve it in two
parts. First, let's see what our load
factor is in a 45°ree bank turn. So
easy. I can literally read the answer
right here. It's 1.414gs.
Now, we need to find our total load.
Remember load factor is the force of
gravity multiplied. So all we have to do
is multiply 1.414gs
times the weight of our aircraft and
1.414
* 1,475
is 285.65.
So it looks like 285 is our answer. Now
please don't be that guy who messages me
and says there's no right answer here.
When I round up I get 286.
Dude, I don't know why, but this is how
the real FAA exam is. You have to pick
the best answer on these. I really think
they do that to try to throw you off,
and it's clearly working. So, be
confident in your answer if it's close.
Don't second guessess yourself. Let's
look at a similar problem, but this
time, let's say the airplane weighs
3,800 lb in a 60° bank turn. Well, golly
G Wilkers. I may not even have to pull
my shoes off for this one. The chart
says we're pulling exactly 2 G's. And
once again, all we have to do is
multiply our weight times the load
factor. And 3,800* 2 equals 7,600 lb.
So, we're putting 7,600 lb worth of
stress on our wings. So, you can see how
important this is to know how to do.
People who don't understand this are the
ones who end up doing this.
Now, before we go, I want to show you
how to calculate one more thing because
it could save your life. Keep in mind
there are charts out there that you can
use to calculate this, but I personally
think that this is something that every
pilot should commit to memory. Don't
worry, it's not anything too crazy. I'm
just messing with you. No, I want you to
remember that the stall speed of your
airplane will increase as the load
factor increases. And it increases by
the square root of your load factor.
Now, don't worry. I think almost every
calculator out there these days has the
square root function. So, this is super
simple to do. The first thing you need
to do is find your load factor. For
example, let's say the DPE asks you this
on the check rod. How much would the
stall speed of our aircraft increase if
we use 60° angle of bank during the turn
onto downwind? Well, we know that by
using this chart, our load factor is
2gs. So, all we have to do is take the
square root of two to find out how much
our stall speed will increase. And in
case you didn't know, that's this button
on the calculator. So, we'll hit that
and then the equals button. And there's
our answer. Our stall speed will be
about 1.42 times the original stall
speed. So, by rounding this number, you
can sound really smart when you tell the
examiner that the stall speed will
increase by 42%.
So, if the original stall speed of our
airplane is 40 knots, all we have to do
is multiply that by 1.42
and that gives us a new stall speed of
56.8 knots. I know I rounded a bunch in
there, so there are some rounding
errors. But please, by all means,
mention that in the comments. It helps
this video. I just won't respond to you.
But anyway, imagine that you're climbing
out at 60 knots and trying to clear an
obstacle, but then you bang the airplane
to 60° to miss a bird. This is where
things start to get really scary because
this puts us super close to our stall
speed. That's why I want you guys to
know how to do this. And I also want you
to see how dangerous it is to overbank
the airplane. Higher bank angles will
lead to higher load factors and that can
lead to a higher stall speed. Now, once
again, don't forget to check out
freepilotraining.net if you haven't
downloaded your testing supplement yet.
That's totally free over there. And you
can also get the premium version of this
course over there for 50 bucks. That
includes the endorsement for the FAA
written exam, over 700 questions worth
of quizzes and practice tests, and I
promise you, you won't be disappointed
with the value compared to those other
schools out there. Thanks for watching.
We'll see you [groaning]